and after 2,000 years in development
Avengers no subtitle it's felt like ages
since it was announced in that Twitter
account got really funny for a little
while when it started seeming like the
game was never going to come but these
things they take time on August who
cares mm instantly dating this video
footage was finally released of the
long-awaited game end it looks pretty
good a lot of folks asked me to give my
thoughts on it when the initial trailer
was released but there were about 3.8
seconds of gameplay on screen for that
and the rest was cutscenes not a lot to
go on really
but this gameplay showcase really went
all out and we got to see a little bit
from everyone so let's break down all
the neat new stuff and maybe along the
way I'll inject some of my trademark wit
and cynicism that people just keep
coming back to fresh off the aftermath
of the unmitigated disaster that was
Ultimate Alliance 3 right your angry
comments now The Avengers game is the
next step in Marvel's quest to make sure
they're the top brand in every art
medium that exists until the end of time
with such big budget blockbusters as
Spider Man and they're working on more
I'd like to first point out the notable
similarity in gameplay to that new god
of war game and how me and my buddies
Diego and Josh totally called that back
in February with our special guest Turks
and meister but that son of a [ __ ] is
making a video on this game right now as
I type this oh boy I hope I can edit
this fast enough to beat him Thor is
throwing around and calling back his
hammer just like the frost axe and
parrying enemies which we assumed would
be specific to him but every avenger
kind of fights like that that if you're
early on that Iron Man's combat would be
entirely flight based and feel like some
kind of flight sim mixed with a rail
shooter' but it turns out that's only
half of the Iron Man gameplay and he can
still hover around and punch dudes on
the ground I only hear Deadpool when he
talks it's very distracting but hey I
think it's cool to finally have a game
where you can do everything an iron can
since the last couple that tried that
fell a little short Black Widows keeping
with her usual theme of jumping onto the
most dangerous flying object she can
find and then somehow not falling off of
it like any normal person would have
she looked different she looks different
cap is the other god of war weapon
exploded Hulk's gameplay isn't quite the
ultimate destruction I was hoping for go
watch those videos by the way but I do
appreciate how powerful and heavy he
looks in gameplay look at him just
climbing along on every semi-truck you
can find as if it were a conveniently
yellow painted object in a naughty dog
game you can't tell me he didn't kill
those guys him and Thor went on a
massacre and everyone thought Spidey was
too lethal just wait till they edit
x-ray moves into this oh god it's
happening right now I'm doing it please
stop me
I like taskmasters design they kind of
split the difference between the classic
look and the udon design which I prefer
a lot more to the Deathstroke II black
from that other game but both of them
are fantastic compared to this
monochromatic lord zedd sob that'll
permeate your eye orbs in the theaters
worldwide next year I was worried this
game would have a lot of MCU influence
to bog it down and judging by Bruce
banners wardrobe that's kind of true but
hey at least the story is original The
Avengers are defeated and lose some of
their key members in a catastrophic
event causing a societal downfall and
for many of them to fall into a state of
depression for a few years before coming
back with an unorthodox way to undo the
damage as a team I know it was one of
those blinking you'll miss at things but
I was most excited by seeing abomination
will be one of the game's boss fights I
do love seeing him and Hulk have some
good old fashioned Man of Steel fights
and it's been over a decade since there
was a good one of those in a game I'm
not talking about that one it feels like
this is a long way to return to the
medium for a lot of these characters
because Marvel seems so allergic to
making any big gaming properties outside
of Spidey for the last nine years
everything we've gotten are MMO games
that imploded flandres ation simulator
2013 a myriad of mobile games that all
look the same
insert mean comment here and you know
those Lego games are pretty good
none of those quite felt like an event
though it's so nice to finally have this
big thing to look forward to for several
months leading to release only to forget
it exists ten months after its come out
do those deals ease I like the inclusion
of Miss Marvel and the Terrigen crystal
thing presumably exploding because now
we can introduce a lot of the Inhumans
characters remember them they're those
annoying things that agents of shield
wouldn't shut up about for three seasons
and then there's this dead-on-arrival
endeavor wouldn't mind them making the
game a little more focused on those
types of characters since the MCU has
left those relatively untouched in any
way that matters it would be nice to see
some of them adapted properly Black Bolt
locked John Medusa may not translate to
live-action well on a TV budget but the
skybox is the limit when it comes to
video games I find it a little humbling
that the graphics in this footage aren't
exactly perfect some of the facial
animation is little off and the textures
on hair and cloth could use some polish
but hey I'd rather that than the demo be
a big lie full of gloss the game won't
have so put those puddles in your pipe
and smoke it
Ubisoft there's a small glimpse at
Avengers tower after being revamped into
an office for a m-- that's not a vengers
tower that's not even the same aim logo
so much for a shared universe [ __ ]
ah that's okay if they get my buddy Yuri
to voice Spidey I can just ignore the
inconsistencies and pretend it's the
same timeline anyway I'm Spyderco
overall I'm very happy with what I'm
seeing here for the game-playing story
despite all the jabs and quips I've
thrown at it this looks like a wonderful
addition to the ever-expanding library
of playable superhero games and I for
one can't wait for Thinnes to be in it
because of course he is learn from this
brave soldier and be patient enough
until we get more news to poke and prod
at and remember we'll watch my dead
space cosplay video that's all good
night just a quick reminder before you
go that I post my videos a day early on
patreon and give exclusive
behind-the-scenes content and patron
exclusive videos please consider
becoming a patron it really helps me out
if you want a more short-term way to
support the channel you can check out my
merch and the links in the description
we have t-shirts phone cases posters
mugs pillows baby onesies and so much
more see you next time
[Music]
[Music]